okay of people joining this livestream
we are talking about the design of a
symbolic layer for external storage
emotion language so um let's see what
we've got here
so this is the analog of
file write and read is that correct yes
we we tried to use the file operations
and the cloud operations as a reference
to design all these ok ok ok so let's
take a look at all of that ok so you're
saying this will be the analog of I mean
so in in the case of ok they're the devs
are definitely right and okay so hold on
a second
you're saying this is the analog of
right
okay okay well let's actually start with
some very basic question which is what
are the clients what are the what are
the services so okay file types right so
we have some services like the usual
ones like Dropbox or Google Drive that
are meant for [ __ ] people like you and
me to put the files but there are newer
ones like Amazon s3 Google storage there
is use with a structure called buckets
like our machine learning team uses that
for right okay
so what is the authentication look like
for any of those things in the case of
of Dropbox or will drive so everything
is we plan to kind of let through
service connect so basically when you
and I have out section there for
authentication if you scroll down we
have a question already on the live
stream will this work with Azure blob
storage
what is blob storage as a diversion of
buckets
I'm sure okay we should find out and
also being asked about Microsoft
onedrive
well yeah onedrive is listed here right
yeah okay and it's not listed here but
we all know yeah I BFS is also there
yeah
and we're also being asked about next
cloud
I don't know what next card is I don't
see own cloud which presumably we might
use but let me understand something the
thing that is about to ship or has just
shipped with the cloud of having
notebooks be able to be opened from
Google Drive what is the relationship
between that than this all right so what
was it questioning in there okay so
we're just shipping now a thing where
you can go to Google Drive and if you
find a notebook in Google Drive you can
open it in our cloud I see now dude who
here knows about that it's Todd here
does he know about that I'm here I know
it exists I don't know about how its
implemented
okay I mean Julian is the expert on how
that's implemented so so one thing I'd
like to flag here is go find out um if
if Carlo if you could send a message
right now to Julian and that maybe late
for him but but Tim ah let's see who
would know this stuff
Matt Kay would probably know this stuff
okay okay ask them for that information
and if they feel like want to join this
meeting they should join it okay tell us
about that okay um okay also the name
it's not a storage right or really was
we wanted to come upload we had a
discussion we thought about having that
as right for now ok but I'm trying to
understand so so the main point here is
these are files okay so the way around
that this is about is from the language
go and plop data into these storage
external storage suffice for retrieval
ok so that's different from essentially
launch from an extra launch in the GUI
in the notebook GUI like like for
example if I go to I mean the whole
point is that you know that we're
supposed to be setting it up so that if
I go to the file browse here right then
I could as well be so I'm in the file
browser I go here I go
um you know double click here I'm gonna
open something um the UM this is some
but the whole point is that I'm I'm um
yeah there's a little document from the
future but but um the UM what am I
saying that that we're um hold on that
that there's an alternative to this view
you'll be able to go to Google Drive and
say open and cloud right so that's the
other way around that's for a notebook
the other way around here you might be
able to say write a notebook too you
know s3 or something just as a place to
store it
and then retrieve it from its URI or
whatever subsequently right yes right
presumably you could use you could use
notebook open or something and give an
external storage object if that pointed
to a notebook storage and write
essentially like a file it's like a file
it's pricey so everything that we okay
everything that is currently like a file
could be replaced by or like a URL could
be replaced by an external storage
object that write which contains I don't
quite understand this I mean what is
there not exactly a file but but that in
a sense that's right even it it's more
like a cloud object really in a sense
that we have a lot of file operations
overloaded to work with cloud objects
have had those file operations
overloaded to work with external storage
but so so what is the typical form of
the okay here we go alright
I'm not thrilled no I don't like this no
I don't like this I mean that's the main
event it's not a frigging you know
footnote option right so column I love
stories noticing that this will be
useful for neural network training data
yeah the reason that we've been using
this we've had a preliminary version of
this ourselves for several years this is
an exposure for the four for everybody
of what we've already been using and
we've used it it's what we've done our
um our machine learning stuff with for a
while go ahead what we gonna say well I
think that - one reason has done this
way a alternative is have the service be
think the first argument or something
and but that's sort of annoying have to
type that every time I mean there's
there's it's kind of like the URL base
in the cloud right there's a cloud base
there's a notion of the current external
storage well so what I said most of the
time you don't have to use that option
right so I mean it's just like cloud
base why why don't we have a thing
called external storage base why don't
we have a dollar external storage base
we do or maybe it's called what they're
called it's just called service which
doesn't make sense no I mean I mean we
have a dollar so that was an area or a
nearly designed what we you just service
because actually we start using method
based on our integrated services
functions since this is an external
service that's what we use as a
reference but isn't there a dollar
variable that holds the discourage or
the default external storage service not
currently but that's something we we
were also in searing um does anybody
know if I have a place to put this in my
um I do external storage I already have
a folder for this probably from a long
time ago well I've got a via sound of
note so I assume you've looked at my
previous round of notes whatever may be
in there yeah okay good
so I think we should do something like
this and this override target yeah
that's obviously what we need which we
have from everything okay so this is
okay dollar external storage base I
guess on the grounds that you'll only be
using one of them now I don't understand
why you're using is there always a
current is there a current directory for
the for the external storage base for
the external storage yeah for the
external storage base is there a current
directory I pray you mean like I did old
one yes yes
nobody said if you didn't provide a
directory will create one for you well
that's all well and good for right but
what about for read so to read if you
scroll down you you'll see that you you
need the path to the to the file or you
need to provide it it doesn't make sense
you've got the wrong way around because
look it's path slash file right
don't these services allow you to
reference a file as part of aisle some
of them yes but you can also provide
external storage object that has all the
information about the external file okay
but but to me the obvious way to do this
would be to say I mean there's an you're
gonna show me external storage object in
a minute here um okay that's a good one
okay import external storage object okay
but what is the what is the actual
structure of an external storage object
is it only something that's returned so
you don't get to type in I mean I don't
get to just define a disembodied
external storage object right like grade
one by yourself no I mean cuz in cloud
object I can do that right if I say
cloud object at hello I've got a cloud
object right right so why wouldn't we do
the same thing with external storage
object
it should probably be something more
similar to a HTTP request where you have
to build it using different fields to
specify the service and and the things
you are using there okay but but
ultimately I don't understand why the
path here is is junior to the file name
I mean isn't the path at least as
important as the file name I don't know
what you mean by that see there's a
junior to the file man was it's it's way
down below here and I okay in this way
okay I there's multiple things I don't
like about this okay so in the case of
URLs we get to just give the URL with
with you know URL wrapper we just get to
give the URL right I don't understand
why we don't have extra storage object
be the same way that is that you can
give the path together with the external
storage base whatever it is you know
something like this right and you could
give it or medication there as well if
I'm not right
yeah you can provide a service object
what about in fact in the file doesn't
exist yet in that service then if you
try and do anything with it it's an
error I mean it's the same thing with
the URL if I go you know import you know
URL quotes hello what's gonna happen is
it's gonna say okay not found even if I
say you know if I say HTTP right just
fail right so I think that's
this should do as well you can define
the external storage object it might
just be you know have nothing to say let
me tell ya but there are some cases like
ipfs so in the case of IPSS ipfs the the
address you get that identifies that
file is one that you only get once you
upload the file to ipfs so you don't
know the address beforehand so far and
you don't get then you don't give it
here then there's nothing to give you
could invent an address and the address
will never you know it's a UUID that
will never be realized right so in other
words you're saying there are systems in
which you don't get to specify the
address it simply tells you the address
just like cloud deploy if you don't give
it a file name simply tells you the
address you see what I'm saying okay
right I don't see a problem with that I
mean so in other words you could give an
address and it just is it doesn't it's
often you know it isn't exactly
cyberspace what is the space you UID
space it's lost in you UID space um okay
so let's keep going here so to my mind I
don't understand why you're breaking
apart the path from the file name I just
don't understand that I mean these
things have um you know if you ever want
to refer to a path without a file name
well they're not that they're not
breaking apart that that's the target
for the can load the file name there is
the target if you're looking external
storage download right yes no no no the
file name is part of the external
storage object right yes okay the first
argument is the external storage object
the second argument is the local path
into which you download this no I'm
looking at this one here I think it's
even isn't very intuitive love ya I'm
referring to this blob here for that
blob there
um oh I see you just not like how its
displayed with I don't like the fact
that the file name is broken apart from
the path I don't understand that because
I don't see how you ever end up using
the file without the path I mean like
like when we have ordinary files on your
local file system or in the cloud for
that matter we do not break apart the
quotes file name from the path see what
I'm saying now I'm assuming that there
is a route effectively in any of these
storage systems as a route that
represents your the route of your
account somehow am i right to understand
what I'm asking you mean every word
folder like a home folder in yes yes yes
look okay yes I strongly do not believe
in breaking these apart we've not done
it okay so let's let's not do that
unless you have an argument otherwise am
I making sense yes yeah okay don't break
them apart now in the case where you
just give a file name what is the
default the default is presumably that
you are in the home directory of
whatever you authenticated with do you
understand what I'm saying yeah so in
this case it will be some time maybe
roll down file name but it should
probably be a complete a full path but
we can also do that like if you just
provide a file name would use search on
the home folder
sorry third again could you repeat I'm
sorry yeah yeah so so I I put finding
there to differentiate between file
names between files and buckets my guy
should be a full fat there but in case
we provide you provide just a file name
we can default to the root folder okay
all right so how do I get okay let's
talk about how you initiate one of these
services because I'm assuming that there
is a way here that you could have an
authentication option inside the
external storage object right which you
scroll scroll down a little bit there's
an authentication section there um okay
yeah so we are considering for now two
types of authentication assuming we when
this case is not going to be the service
option but in case we use the external
storage base option you can provide yes
a regular string and if the service asks
you for authentication it will ask the
user to authenticate if not you can
authenticate using the service connect
and provide your syndicated service
object okay so hold on hold on hold on
hold on so if the external storage base
is like this right if I say external
storage base equals service connect of
Dropbox for example right then that will
evaluate to a service object having
requested the authentication correct
right or in case you have the connection
saved you will use that safe connection
I understand but service connect will be
will will use the saved connection
correct right okay so in this case here
if I say external storage base arrow
quotes Dropbox what's it gonna do is it
then go into on first uses of send in a
request authentication right II need
like you it would it will create a
service connection
and it will it will run service connect
okay on first use yeah okay so they say
you want to have different let's say you
have to Dropbox accounts for you're
going to do keeper files so you can
provide two different service objects to
two different accounts right so this one
well what will this do by default if you
just give quote to Dropbox or should you
not do that yeah yeah that should work
and and and it should open the Dropbox
website since don't you wait no no no no
no if you've got two different drop
boxes you've authenticated two of them
right you've got service objects for two
different Dropbox accounts and now you
say external storage base our Dropbox
which of your Dropbox accounts does it
uses that will create a third connection
oh yeah okay all right okay
that's a little funky okay so the most
common cases you do a service connect to
connect to do the authentication now I
don't know how this is going to relate
to system services right the the the the
Brad system services project have you
guys been following that I know what
abridging my name then follow me okay so
that project involves for example let's
say you have a geoserver you want to say
I want to use this particular geoserver
I want to use this particular URL
shortener service server okay this seems
very related to that and I think you
should talk to him about that okay okay
it's also related to things like you
know which installation of Python are
you using in the external evaluate
system but I understand this that looks
pretty reasonable okay um now the
authentication so are you saying if I
say service connect I would put I could
put an authentication here explicitly or
I could wait for the web to prompt me is
that correct
why doesn't service connect work with
authentication Christian why will I will
need to check
fine yes but so so in principle though
it's horrible practice but people do it
all the time you can burn in a notebook
you could burn your authentication
credentials into the notebook actually
actually the right way to do it which is
beautiful is to use system credentials
right you understand how those work so
that's the system keychain that's coming
in twelve one right and you've got a
hidden system keychain that's
authenticated on your machine then you
just pass it in your notebook through
the system keychain to the
authentication of the external service
that should work just fine
okay right all right um okay we have a
few questions on the live stream here
can we use as three services yes the
answer is yes GPU and I will cloud
machine the trends my network but I want
to be able to do much talking a local
computer yes that is what that is what
we've been doing for the last several
years so we think that works because
that's exactly what we built this for um
let's see somebody wants to UM yeah yeah
brian is pointing out that a zero should
be supported yes that is certainly our
intention and for reasons not to be
discussed yet that will definitely be
supported um okay so Ethan is saying 4s3
please support multi-factor
authentication what is the story with
that we'll have to check but we are
using the the SDK provided by Amazon so
if they they may support that we should
support it as well
okay please make sure that s3 bucket
keys are paged up loaded and downloaded
in parallel threads do you understand
what that's about
well about parallel threads we also have
some questions at the at the end of the
node related a synchronous tasks
okay fine all right we'll get to that
then okay
how would this work with net train so I
think in that case this is one of these
cases where let's see the the AWS link
which actually runs on AWS right as
opposed to the s3 link which is the
stuff the AWS link is a different
project right where it's actually
running computations on AWS correct
AWS link is just an exposure of the
whole set of AWS api's or from language
okay but I mean this separate project
which is going to be Jesse and those
guys is actually having I mean something
we've been doing for a long time is
actually being able to run the you know
Wolfram engine on AWS so that you can
have an s3 bucket full of machine
learning examples and then run the
engine on on AWS across that s3 bucket
right AWS link is just a tool for that
system
okay that's just what do you mean isn't
that system it's it's I mean AWS link is
the thing that we would use to create
that system you know the ability to add
launch and right but that's a that's a
subsequent project which we have you
know green-lighted but is not is not yet
fully active right yes okay um okay
let's go back up here all right so I
don't completely understand the
difference between why is that not
upload play me for that and I I've
already backed off it's definitely not
parallel to the right function I was the
one who didn't like external storage
upload and I have to be changed but what
are we doing footer what wait wait what
what is the analogous thing for I mean
for for remote file systems right remote
when you have a remote file you're just
using copy file aren't you to do the
upload stuff
if you want to upload to a random
service somewhere um you are do we have
anything called upload there's a data
been uploaded I think okay yeah copy
file should work with with remote files
because it supports SSH okay so what
you're saying is that I could do a copy
file to an external storage object or
from an external storage object so it is
equivalent copy file from an external
storage object to a local file is
equivalent to external storage download
that correct that should be similar yes
similar but but external storage
download works for bucket type objects
whereas copy file would not should we
design that or did we decide that just
creates a directory I guess I guess I
create a directory so yeah copy file
capable of correcting directory just
copy file create directories you know we
mean when G or with a bucket and you
don't load that it will create a
directory with the files
I guess copy files doesn't work with
buckets sorry why doesn't it work with
buckets again because at a leaf from
documentation copy file yes works with
single files
so from file1 file2 in the case of a
bucket we are thinking that external
storage download will create a directory
with all the files from the bucket there
sorry I spaced for a second because I
was watching stuff from the life sister
on on upload right now I'm sorry on on
download right now from a bucket copy
file does what
so copy file words with single files
right okay but what happens if you copy
file a directory we have a way to copy a
directory don't we is it called copy
directory yeah yes
okay so copy directory would presumably
copy a bucket or not I'm not completely
sure if we if we should call a bucket
and directory yeah I'm not sure I got I
think that the extension of copy file is
a little it is gonna get a little bit
hickey somewhere because I think it's
going to between authentication and
things like this and multiple
authentications where it's going to and
from it could get very messy I mean you
could use a copy file well here's a
question if you want a copy between
external storage objects how do you do
that yes that's another thing we have at
the end of notebook so we were thinking
about having a certain external storage
copy symbol or trying to use something
like copy file copy for work between two
remote files anybody know I think it
should work because it supports multiple
Brotherhood for remote stuff okay hoping
works between two cloud objects - well
we should check that copy file working
so I think that I'm reversing myself
here and thinking that that would be
okay too and presumably delete file will
work against an external storage object
also yes right yeah so we are trying to
know why why do we have any of these
functions why do we have any of this why
do we have external storage put I mean
the reason we have cloud put it's
because we have anonymous cloud putting
that's why it's useful to have cloud put
otherwise we might as well just say
export to a cloud you say
well we do have an animus external
storage court to do we do all these
services support anonymous UUID
destinations
well IBF says I understand black DFS
does no nothing else nothing else is
supported well can't you call external
storage court with a lot of these
different services but just we'll just
the expression to put and it creates its
own file and just ran that's my question
right that's my PFS obviously does that
just as the cloud does it does s3 for
example create random file names like uu
IDs well in the case of s3 this will not
work with a tree because it we've
thought about these working just with a
files type services because it doesn't
make sense to put something in a bucket
it is just an expression
why not why do you want to use her
bucket for storing just one expression I
mean I don't sound if it's just like why
would you use the cloud to start why
would you use a cloud object to store
one expression yes they'd be as out of
services like s3 is to work with a lot
of files and that's why they have these
buckets no I understand that but what
I'm suggesting is that you you identify
a bucket then you're running a loop
where you're basically throwing a
million items in there each one with the
UUID sure I'm saying it's like a bucket
of expressions yes yes written out
presumably the default and this is an
interesting question should be in wxf
she just writes an expression I mean I
don't know you know like when you write
to the cloud we're not telling you
what's inside the cloud object right and
it often is wxf if I'm understanding
correctly at least so what I'm
suggesting is that external storage put
would be putting let's say I mean the
one argument form of that is just an
expo that puts it in the default cloud
base as an external storage object
containing wxf so that were you to call
that external storage object way to say
well in this particular case you could
actually say get external storage object
you would just get back just like you
would if this was a file right the only
difference the only advantage to have an
external storage put is that you are I
mean put itself is a two argument
function right no it's not what does it
do if you put what does put do if you
just have one argument or creates an
empty file okay all right but but um
what can you handle authentication let's
get with which I'm so much but no with
get if you do get external storage
objects well I assume the external
storage option contains the
authentication we could do that but we
haven't discussed about it yet
okay I mean the gate could also have a
ton of Education option I mean
we do have a separate cloud get to avoid
confusion okay I I think it's sort of
unnecessary right I mean I agree with
that it if you've got an external object
you can tell all the other functions how
to work with that like yet and all that
but so you don't really need external
storage get but it's a nice just like we
have with cloud Getty you know what you
think know what you know what you know
what the correct thing to do here is
this to use put exper comma external
storage object open close because that
like cloud object oh compose creates a
you you ID'd external storage object
that's the right way to do right not to
have an external estimate but you know
what works the same way with cloud
object and we do have cloud put I am
aware of that but that's because we
didn't think of this
I mean maybe the cloud would for the
push function they do take a one
argument form this just the expression
so you say cloud put it knows to create
a cloud object near on set point and and
forget doesn't need that because you you
have the object I know I know it noses
but but I mean do we keep the get for
just a little hell yeah we have close
again we're gonna have the put we have
to keep the get I I kinda it was
probably have these two functions yeah
okay so explain to me why upload and
download why does it download a file
what's the difference oh it's
downloading a file what do we have it we
don't have a cloud download do we know
URL download right but cloud download
would be part of the cloud syncing
mechanism right because it's taking a
cloud and a file from the cloud and
copying it right right means URL
download works with
objects we don't we don't really need
cloud download because it doesn't give
anything that URL download doesn't
already do okay well would the same be
true of external storage object that URL
download could do that too it's not
really a URL URL it's not our URL I mean
it makes it sound like we really should
have a function called download that
works from the cloud and from anything
else just like we have get and put um I
mean I tend to feel that what we should
do is have experimental functions which
are external storage download etcetera
etcetera etcetera that it's conceivable
that will package everything together
and simply overload default you know
generic functions okay
upload a list of files to an external
storage thing or a directory presumably
external storage upload should upload
next a directory to the external storage
device service yep okay sandir is saying
you know do we really want an importer
download get um oh what download those
will do different things I mean get
reads in wolf language code import reads
and whatever it reads in download is
copying the file from there to here but
we don't have external source download
okay external storage import right I
mean we've kept in to a bare minimum we
haven't caught the cloud has a bunch of
functions with no cloud x clouded why I
think that we just just call import of
an external storage object rather than
having external storage import it
we've kept the API quite minimal we just
have to get what and I know but I'm not
even sure given that we don't have the
import and export it's unclear to me
that we need look I suspect that we
should have as generic functions
upload/download I mean upload and
download are very similar to copy file
crisis completely unclear to me why we
have anything other than copy file
except for the fact that it's not
conceptually um you know it it feels
wrong to just have everything be copy
file let's keep going with this and
let's let's loop back to this um all
these things implemented yet I mean oh
do we have we have our test back lit
lovely ok ok and what we have tried is
we drop bugs and ipfs ok but we also
have separately in s3 link which
presumably will make it work with us
three right yeah we are reviewing all
those SDKs and everything that the
bucket type services provide ok what
happens if you want to list what in a
bucket IV scroll down to the storage
object you will see something like that
price if you go to hold on buckets and
chips and okay I don't have any idea why
this isn't file names of external
storage object yeah yeah that should
work so we were thinking about having so
the storage object will have properties
right so one of the properties will list
the files like in the in that case it's
perfectly nice
the house dataset it's kind of nice I
mean arguably this files data set we
should have the analog of file names
able to do that the very least there
should be a function repository function
that does that for a directory Oh
whenever you see say data set of your
files with all that information link
doesn't sound right
what is length the amount of files you
have in the bucket then it should say
something like file count or something
not length yeah length is very obscure
but I wonder if this file is the right
word I mean if session is not really
what kind of stretching it to call these
things inside a bucket files right what
are they using what are they usually
called in these services am I wrong
about that do they call these things
inside bucket files or is that not
really the liner it has really no they
use a different name haven't heard
another name you Silas all right that
should be called service name if it's
just the string okay unser vez
should be service should extract the
service object I see um
okay creation date of the bucket yeah I
agree I mean import should do
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba what is import
doing with the directory country
I don't think it works but arguably and
that would be a question for shadi um
import of a directory should do the same
thing here
well I want to try that but I want to
kill my machine and leave that live
stream so I'll try later okay um okay so
this concept of the next tunnel storage
object I guess for a cloud object what
are the properties of a cloud object
your typical does he is there a URL
property there various properties of
cloud objects Yes No maybe
yeah I mean see if this properties
selector returns and doesn't seem to
this is not good oh boy look this is a
different thing this doesn't have oh
what a mess this is using the
information mechanism which we hadn't
discussed for cloud objects I'm for
external storage objects right so if I
do
okay now I say that son 75 Sabha
mimetype if I say information percent 75
mimetype then it does work
humph what we probably should make it
work with sub values what do you think
yeah I'm actually no reason to not have
it workers for those almost all the I'm
does URL work with sub values because
there's no reason you can't extract the
URL path for the sub value then or even
file work with sub values think about
gonna have it when they bought well okay
so we let's look at that getting them
altar to work with sub values okay but
otherwise for this for right now we can
have it work with information for the
external storage object make sense so
with information and and the properties
here or just check so no no no I mean
information can give a whole bunch of
properties as it does for other things
right so if I say information of percent
75 it'll give that whole info box thing
then that will be a very nice thing for
it to give for the external storage
object right okay I like that very much
actually um so fine so that's what we
should do whether we subsequently decide
to make everything be accessible with
sub values is an interesting question
but if we're gonna do it we should do it
for all types of storage objects makes
sense yeah let me ask you another
question are we sure we want to call
these external storage objects not
storage object
so I'm trying to think about local
object and what will be the difference
if a local object is storing something I
left : external storage I mean I'm just
trying to think whether I mean it's just
like a file well we have the notion of a
remote file versus a local file so I
agree external storage object seems
right okay um there are a bunch of
questions here querying the external
storage system for how much file space
is remaining for instance in other words
these global things that will be a
service connect query right yeah yeah so
we are we want to support all these
services also the service connect so you
can do that kind of operations through
the service connection so we typically
look like service execute of service
object of spy I don't know right user
data we have file space remaining or
something so how we would looked at
standardizing those those queries for
the different services or is it really
hopeless and messy are we are we gonna
be able to have a common set of
properties for across all those services
that's right that's what we're trying to
do all this year with this service
connection so we'll try to here but I I
would say that we probably have some
kind of a standard for the bucket type
and for the file web services no Sharif
oh okay fine but so long as we have a I
mean it could be bucket space remaining
and something else but I mean and you
know no doubt ipfs will have funky
exceptions like it you know it's
infinite space and things like this
right um okay but so let's get a list of
those properties and try and see whether
we can get a common subset right other
questions on the live stream is there
any way to get
summary of how much data was written
during a session that's interesting
that's an interesting issue so that will
be interesting issue I mean to record
that in the service object right did you
understand the point that if if you by
accident wrote a terabyte you'd kind of
like to know that before I mean in other
words the service object could show you
how much data there was and it could be
a queried of the service object how much
data had been written you know in other
words the session
I don't know session storage what would
it be called session what will be the
session storage size or something I
don't know um that's a good suggestion I
mean we don't have that for for files it
just does what it does but I agree that
since these things are specifically
costing money by by bytes we might want
that by the way don't forget to have
units on the various bite sizes and
things right but it isn't I'll similar
case with cloud like people say pay for
cloud and they all search true yeah I
mean we don't really record that I don't
know how I mean that that's in the cloud
logging data right so it's - suggestion
I mean you can clearly get the
information from the service itself but
it will be good to have a standard query
of the service object which would give
you this um okay
nice tell the mechanism to limit the
amount of data written to a storage
device to prevent unexpected charges
caused by program error that's an
interesting idea that's an interesting
idea
um so I mean that would be the analog of
time constraint era whatever
- I mean we could imagine something
external storage constraint I suppose
but then you got no to use it seems like
might be an option to service women when
you connect the service to say limit my
uploads you know then it the bytes -
yeah I mean I'm not sure how you error
out of that it could be a bit messy to
her out of it all except for the last
byte in in fair right no no I understand
that but I'm just thinking about
unwinding a program as it errors out but
I think you should look at that when you
connect to the service question let's
let's look at whether you can specify a
constraint at that stage okay yeah
because the only way you can write
things to the service is through a file
operation right like a like an export
for example and you know it's
interesting I mean one could imagine one
could imagine even an export and I don't
know whether this makes any sense but
one could a man
having something like that I don't know
why one would care that seems like the
kind of thing we would have put in in
the 1980s and taken out sometime in the
intervening period right because that's
the thing you know oh I'm writing a file
but I don't want it to be too big okay
Holly is asking um complaining about
focus being less on the card or more on
the desktop we are doing lots of stuff
on the desk job do not worry the um lots
of things on the desktop uh okay let's
let's look at the let's look at these
things at the bottom here external
storage to submit right so we're
thinking that all these functions you
you saw are for synchronous tasks right
so we have stuff like I don't know like
URL download submit your submit but in
this case we should have something for
uploading and downloading files correct
we want we want both operations to have
a a synchronous version yeah I mean I
guess for download and upload but the
other things I mean doesn't make a lot
of sense
anything that returns right those things
so I mean okay so this is the
asynchronous case um I mean I would
think that that will force us to have a
download and an upload function because
I don't think we want to have um I mean
I have to believe I mean right now
data been uploaded right that is for
uploading a whole data bin by the way a
question that was asked much earlier in
this in this discussion was about the
resource system and its relationship to
these things so let's address that
question for a second I believe although
nobody is here from the resource system
team but I believe that the resource
system would have no trouble referring
to an external storage object is that
also what other people here believe so
basically using a resource object as an
argument and save that dukkha sir no sir
ish
no no no I mean that when you deploy
something to the resource system okay
which you don't do you have to I mean
that that's a thing let's see how is
this work um just look resource submit
now that's for submitting to a proper
repository how do you do this I am
confused for a moment here um
how do you do that
how do you upload you do this cloud
deploy of a resource object I think you
do oh yeah cloud publishable resource
object right that provides that's not
encouraging
whoever's peering here please make a
note of that go get it track down growl
okay but I believe that what we can do
there is what we're saying is um if you
say resource object and you say cloud
publish of the resource object okay
here's a question for external storage
how does it work with a CDN because we
have a quite separate you know two
questions the for the Wolfram
application server anybody here Todd
knows about that do you know about that
that's an android project that yeah I
mean yes I do
what's your question about that so the
upload mechanism so more from
application server when you deploy a an
API you are uploading assets into the
server right actually you're uploading
it into the container because that how
does that work it gets cloned because
the container can be cloned right so I
don't completely know how that works but
fundamentally you're uploading assets
that become the files called by the web
server when you go to that URL right
right and how does that upload work what
is that upload do you know I don't what
you mean how does it work I mean no I I
mean what's that what's the function
that causes you I think we we were
talking about having service having a
service execute that does that upload I
doubt
they have created that yet okay so I
would speculate that we should have an
external storage system what about
external storage and they wolf map okay
so storage cases okay other cases so I
claim one case is wolf an application
server and I claim another case as a CDN
okay like when we upload stuff to our
CDN I do you have any idea how that
works I have no idea I assume there's an
API but does it anybody here know how
that works okay anything that has an API
I think could be plugged into this no I
know the question is whether what you
deliver at the other end is because the
the thing about a CDN yeah I think it's
the same story I think a CDN is a good
example of an external storage area I
think both of those cases are which
means that we should be able to have
these same functions for both of those
okay so the issue is upload submit
download submit these are
fire-and-forget functions as in you say
go ahead and download you're not gonna
look at that file yet it's just gonna
happen somewhere in the background and
eventually you can have a callback that
tells you it's ready that right but I
kind of think that this is a great
example of why we should genericized
download and upload okay I also think
that in the case of this data bin thing
that fundamentally it should be upload
and then there should be a symbolic date
event specifier and then the payload
that makes sense
alright so another
this becomes that becomes purely upload
to a database of the payload right yes
anybody understanding yeah okay so my
question is you know there is no cloud
upload right now it's copy file for the
cloud right right so I think we should
have just as a convenience and uploading
a download function that works to the
cloud because we can then have upload
the equivalent of cloud upload submit
which seems like a useful function right
and those are the building blocks for
the sync system the synchronization
system right okay also so now that you
were talking about the resource object
so just to make a note about what you
said about the external storage object
that if you put let's say an address on
ipfs it doesn't exist the resource
object doesn't know that but if you try
right now I mean the external storage
object if you try resource object and do
something like hello that returns an
error so that behavior is different so I
think it's only returning I predict that
it's only doing that if it's if it's if
it's structure is wrong I think if I
were to pick this up here um and feed
that in to that resource object I
predict it is not going to error out
oops
oh okay I mean the grease our system
does go it's active you take resource
object it goes and does something okay
and what's wrong with that I mean the
resource because the resource system has
the feature that it is caching locally
always right which is nothing to do with
an external storage object I mean that's
the difference that's why resource
objects exist and on just cloud objects
for example is they have a lot of other
management features right right right
exercising will be the cloud object your
proposal that you can type it and
nothing happens until you try to use it
and yes it might alright so arguments I
am my conclusion here is that we should
attempt to not have external storage put
and get that we should just have I
thought you I thought you concluded that
we do want storage pudding I recant
supporting because of the fact that we
got upload and download and we just
don't want to multiply those functions
the only thing that we lose is not
having to type there's a tiny bit of
extra typing to do is saying put blah
blah blah comma external storage object
of no arguments I think that's a corner
case I think the number of people who
want to put anonymous stuff into
external storage is not large it's much
smaller than the number of people who
want to put anonymous stuff into the
cloud which is a very common thing to
want to do
I think we should attempt to do this
without having an external storage but
okay but I think we should introduce
download and upload I think we should
introduce those to be the equivalent of
copy file for cases where they can be ok
and then I think we should have dug out
upload and download submit and have
those work with the cloud and I think we
should get rid of data bin upload should
deprecated that and make and replace
that by upload to date have been makes
sense ok yeah I wonder whether on just a
generic upload function and download
will won't hit some case where we it may
even can't work the same across all it
may I don't see it right now but it
might I mean the main issue is with
anonymous things because if it isn't
anonymous it's kind of ok right and I
think you know another thing you can
imagine is an upload to a service right
where all you give is the service object
and it somehow creates the I mean so
long as all these things return their
final location that's ok
right ok let's do one last look here um
what we've got here so we've got a
dollar external storage base which is
the default thing that is from a service
connect returning a service object
external storage base is an option
that's kind of stupid actually because
it's an option to one function namely
external storage object well it's ok
it's similar to blockchain based and so
on
you usually set dollar blockchain base
yes but for I think the
the animal case will be the bludgeon
transaction where we don't have bludgeon
based option but it's a property of the
transaction that's because you've
already got blockchain objects in the
transaction right which know their
blockchain base right you need to keep
that there so what is the thing
blockchain transactions semester for
example well yeah if you go there watch
intersections to me you will see the
whole example going from creating a
transaction to submitting the third
section I'll give it this has a
blockchain transaction which contains
about chain base but I assume that if I
were to put this as a symbol outside the
Association here that it would also work
and canonicalize to being inside the
Association is that true just like if
I'd set dollar blockchain base that that
would find its way into the Association
correct if it doesn't work that way it
should yeah I think we talked about this
maybe should work out okay all right
okay yeah by the idea behind this is
that the blockchain transaction object
needs this property so that's why we
don't have it as a as an option all
right done that the same idea with the
story object I don't let me explain let
me understand a little bit more
carefully so you're saying why is it not
an argument to the external storage
object what is the service not an
argument to the external storage object
because if you so if you lose that piece
of information you can't connect again
so if you if you want to send a whole
external search object do you need to
have that property inside not that is
another others room
vote firework remote file has to know
let me look at remote file on a remote
machine I see so that's got in the URI
that's got the specification of the
remote machine right because using the
SCP protocol or something like that
right right okay and there's no base in
the URI for an external storage object
there's no like AWS s3 : base or
something is there from which you can
deduce what you're talking about
or is there so we found it also we
discuss about it wasn't ipfs have a base
- doesn't it have your eyes it has
addresses that I know no no but I
understand but it doesn't it have a
transport specification isn't it like
ipfs : bla bla bla
so that's what I'm trying to understand
is from the URI can you deduce the
service type do you know sir
no when they know that about IBSS sorry
could you repeat the question yes so can
you reference something in ipfs with so
how'd it go like they said like as you
see here and remote file that you have
SCP and the part of the question is
whether these services have you our eyes
that specify the service in the URI not
really at least not for the case of
Amazon or neither for what does it look
like what is the path for Amazon look
like well they have a path for their
api's for series and they who use URI
parameters
for example Amazon uses the bucket ID
and the file id and ipfs use what is the
prefix what is the transport protocol
prefix for there you are eyes like
what's the analog of HTTP what what what
do they use what is the transport
protocol that they are using they use
HTTP oh really okay all right fine
okay all right well I guess this is
right I I still want to look at this one
more time but why don't you go ahead and
implement it this way okay um okay
question was in our live stream comes
complaint from Gustavo for download
submit an URL submit one gets into
trouble if one submits too many an
option to limit the number of
simultaneous connections would be very
useful not sure we have the right set of
people here to address that oh do you
know anything about that well I
understand the question I I thought that
we had some limit of like 6 threads or
something I mean it I guess the issue is
that the other service can complain and
reject these downloads or uploads
because you're trying to why don't we
look into this what didn't you take that
is sutala why don't you take that issue
and ask for him what the story is with
it okay yeah can you can talk to me it
could clarify it in the future if you
need okay next question um will won't be
able to use set directory to an external
storage location yeah I was wondering
that myself um in other words I think
the answer that is it's kind of hopeless
the UM that will operate on what under
like if you have two two connections to
Dropbox let's say you'll have to use set
directory on this therapies object
I'm sure I'm sorry so if if you say the
issue is could you do a set directory to
a bucket location or something and then
be referring to files sort of with wild
abandon with just their file names
it seems challenging to me to do that oh
it's the issue would be you know whether
you can do you know that the proposition
would be set directory to an external
storage object I don't think that
committee Erebus isn't it to the service
of a service the argument no because
you're going inside the service right
you're looking at a particular bucket
inside that service it's somewhat more
complicated because the poorly named
directories write that directory right
has you know the
what's the analog of that directory
right could you set that directory to be
I I think this is hopeless
I mean I think it's like saying set it
to be a remote file I think it just gets
deeply tangled I would say the answer is
no not for the time being
um any comments at all do you understand
the issue I mean I it looks hopeless to
me well yeah I mean I think it and I
could imagine if say Dropbox supports a
notion in their API of setting the
current directory for future operations
on this connection then I could imagine
like I doubt they do and and it's
turning not going to generic across
connections well let's find out whether
they do but also you seen
set directory on the external storage
object I don't think it makes like too
much sense because that object is
representing it's a representation of a
remote file and you're said well the
thing one could do which is a little bit
funky is set directory could return a
modified external storage object which
contains in it somewhere a setting for
current directory so what I'm saying I
mean right now set directory is a pure
side-effect operation does not affect
its argument but we could return well I
should know what it returns is the
directory you went to right which is in
a sense comes from nowhere because it's
a pure side-effect he thing in this case
we could be synthesizing a
representation of the directory you go
to how you use that and how do you use
that thing it hasn't written it back
yeah okay all right so so then it would
have to modify ie aai it would have to
yeah that would have to write itself
back - yeah that would have to you know
would have to write back
to the service object before that seems
like a lot of work just to avoid having
split stole tack names all the time you
know right well let's explore that later
okay I think that's not for right now
okay anything else we should figure out
here other than terrific project and you
know I think I think a thing that I
would like to comment on and please
please communicate with Brad about this
about the system service business
because I could imagine people who want
to set up a resource system like a data
repository on s3 for example and I think
this plumbing should allow that to work
making sense I mean right now
well maybe not the question is what's
the analog of cloud deploy or cloud put
sea cloud put no actually it should work
it should work so so long as you can get
into the resource object and tell it
that the storage location that the
location of the of the of the resource
is in s3 then it should just work I
believe right now if you do a cloud
deploy of a resource object it will make
sure to package everything up for the
cloud the analog of that here is less
clear
so I'm saying I mean there is a this is
a weird case right so you could imagine
something like an external storage
deploy I I don't really understand this
yet
okay where basically what you're doing
is to say oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
what this is
I know what this is this is the analog
of service deploy remember service
deploy which I think we still haven't
implemented a case of but you remember
what this is this is what male receiver
function deployment should be what
service deploy does
is it takes some active service that you
are trying to define and it posts it
into an external into an external way to
deliver services okay so for example
let's imagine that well let like an
Alexa skill would be an example of one
of these right that's what I use in my
mind whenever you talk about this
function right so I mean it's something
that is kind of complicated and it it
requires that you've packaged up a
specification of symbolic specification
of an external service that you can
there and then what this then does is it
posts that external service it it hooks
that external service into the what
would you call it into the sort of you
know deployment area for the external
service so you know as an Alexa skill a
bot that is being you know I don't know
a slack bot or something same type of
thing right so I mean you know examples
being Alexa skill slack bot dot dot dot
but I think here am I completely
confused that you could imagine a
service deploy to s3 effectively of a
resource object
I claim am I completely confused what
why would this be different than upload
of the resource object
I mean what's for deploy I mean the
cloud deploy you're you're doing things
to this object I can API function or
something you you just packaged up in a
special way yeah this external service
external sources you're just blasting
them into the external storage the issue
is the hooking ok so what it really is
ok what what you're really doing is
deploying it into essentially an s3
resource system because the issue is
just like you have to
look into slack to say access my slack
bot in this way right if you want that
resource to be accessible from the
resource system that you have set up
it's got to be hooked into the resource
system oh yeah I don't fully understand
this yet coming later all right anything
else to talk about here nope process
great looks very nice thank you all and
thanks folks on the livestream that was
a very useful set of comments much
appreciated see y'all soon